ما هي المراه سؤالي بان بديهي لكنه تحول
لملف صراع سياسي جديد وجديد دراما الامير
هاري مثول امام المحكمه للشهاده وحبس
الموظفين اجدد اساليب الاداره اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ما هي المراه
هذا عنوان فيلم مدته 95 دقيقه وقالب
العالم وخصوصا على تويتر الفيلم نزل فيه
20 22 لكن على تويتر الشركه المنتجه له
والمنصه الاعلاميه المحافظه ديلي واير
نزلته من ثلاثه ايام وقالت انها تبغى الكل
يكون عنده فرصه يشوف الفيلم مجانا لمده 24
ساعه الفيلم كما هو واضح من اسمه بناقش
تعريف المراه موضوع بيبان بديهي وبسيط لكن
للاسف مؤخرا بسبب تحرك اليساريين
المتطرفين المعروفين باصحاب ثقافه الوق
صار موضوع شائك وصعب
[موسيقى]
الفيلم من تقديم وانتاج ماتورش المؤلف
والمقدم المحافظ واللي محول هذا الموضوع
لقضيه حياته ايش الموضوع الموضوع انه كثير
من اليسريين والمتطرفين ومع تصاعد الحديث
عن حقوق الاقليات صاروا بينادوا انه من حق
اي احد يعرف عن نفسه بالجنس اللي بغاه
يعني يجي رجل حابب يعرف عن نفسه انه امراه
فيعتبروا انه هذا الموضوع من حقه ولازم
نتعامل معاه على هذا الاساس والموضوع زاد
لدرجه صار بيغيروا في المناهج وفي اللغه
يعني بيقولوا انه ما نقول نساء حوامل بل
نقول اشخاص حوامل وانه ما نقول الستات
اللي بتجيهم الدوره الشهريه بل الاشخاص
اللي بتجيهم الدوره الشهريه شايفين يعني
انه في ناس بيولوجيين شيء لكن بيختاروا
انهم يعرفوا عن نفسهم بجنس اخر الفيلم
بيعارض الفكره وبيطحطها بقوه وبيقول علميا
ما هي المراه وانه اي شيء ثاني ما اسمه
مراه الفيلم عليه اكثر من 170 مليون
مشاهده على تويتر في ثلاثه ايام وتقريبا
200 الف رتويت ونصف مليون لايك
موضوع الفيلم مثل ما قلنا الشائك وحساس
ومتحول لملف سياسي اساسي يعني صاير شعار
من شعارات الاحزاب والفرقاء السياسيين وفي
بلد مثل امريكا مثلا هو الان ملف اساسي
على طاوله الانتخابات المقبله فعندنا
بايدن الديمقراطي اللي بيدعم حق كل شخص
انه يعرف عن جنسه مثل ما هو يبغى في
مرشحين مثلا مثل عن الحزب الجمهوري اللي
بيوعد بانه يوقف الوك عند حدهم وحتى زوجته
من كم يوم طلعت لابسه جاكيت بيحاربهم علنا
وصراحه الجاكيت عليه خريطه فلوريدا اللي
هي الولايه اللي زوجها حاكمها ومكتوب
عليها هنا سيموت الوق
وفي وقت الاصوات الديمقراطيه في العالم
وتحديدا هوليود والاعلام الغربي بتدعم
الوقحه كل شخص يعرف عن نفسه مثل ما يبغى
بدات تطلع الاصوات المحاربه للفكره مثل ما
قلنا مثلا مثال
واحد من اهم الاصوات المؤثره في محاربه
هذه الثقافه الماسك اللي سبق و هاجم تطرف
الليبراليين اعاد تغريد الفيلم وعلق عليه
انه كل الاهالي اللازم يشوفوا الفيلم وقال
انه انا مع انه البالغين الموافقين حرين
يعملوا اللي يبغوه عشان يكونوا سعداء لكن
بدون ما ياذوا الاخرين لكن الاطفال ما
عندهم القدره يوافقوا او لا وعلشان كده
لازم يكون في قوانين تحميهم طبعا تغريده
ماسك حولت الوثائقي وجذبت الملايين
لمشاهدتهم ماسك الزمان لمن هاجم الووكر
بيهاجم فكره انه تويتر بي افكارهم وارائهم
بس وعرض امثله حيه على هذا الشيء ووعد انه
تويتر راح يعرض كل الاراء ويبدو انه عرض
هذا الفيلم اول خطوه كيف تويتر من بعد ما
كان عامل اتفاق مع صناع الفيلم للترويج له
وعرضه على المنصه لمده 24 ساعه مجانا رجع
لغى العقد معاهم وقالوا انه السبب انه
الفيلم فيه حالتين ان وصف فيهم اشخاص بجنس
غير اللي بيعرفوا عن نفسهم فيه ماسك لما
شاف كلام صناع الفيلم عن الموضوع رد عليهم
وقول لهم اللي صار خطا من بعض العاملين في
تويتر والموضوع طبعا مسموح وقال ماسك انه
استعمال ضمائر مخالفه للضمائر لشخص بيفضل
يتنادى فيها هو وقاحه دون شك لكنه ليس
قانوني من الاخر بيقول لهم ما في قانون
بيقول انه اذا ناديت احد بغير الضمير اللي
بيستخدمه يعني من الاخر غير الجنس اللي
بيعرف عن نفسه فيه
قانوني عادي يعني وسمح ماسك بالترويج
للفيلم على تويتر عشان كل اللي قلناه
سابقا هذا بنقول اليوم انه تعريف المراه
تحول لصراع سياسي وفي وقت في ناس مع انه
كل واحد بيعرف عن نفسه مثل ما يبغى في ناس
شايفه انه جنون وتطرف في الديمقراطيه وانه
في اشياء ما بتخضع للقهواء والاراء
الشخصيه في علم في بيولوجيا في حقائق غير
قابله للتغيير طبعا هنا لازم ننوه
مشاهدينا انه نحنا ما بنتكلم ابدا عن اللي
عندهم مرض او اضطراب والطب يستدعي تحولهم
نحن بنتكلم هنا عن اللي بيعرفوا عن نفسهم
من غير جنسهم بس لانهم حاسين بهذا الشيء
ويبغوا الكل يتعامل معاهم على هذا الاساس
ويوافقوهم طيب نحن معانا من لندن الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور احمد عجاج اهلا
فيك معانا دكتور احمد اول شيء خليني ابتدي
معاك من مصطلح الووك اصلا البدايه بدايه
هذا المصطلح ما كان كيف ما صار الان
يستخدم ايش اللي طرق على التعريف بحيث
وصلنا الان لهذا النوع او لهذا التعريف
طبعا هو التطور التاريخي بهذا الامر عندما
بدا كان مساله تتعلق بالحقوق عامه وحريات
اساسيه لكن مع الوقت يعني تطورت هذه
الحقوق واصبحت تاخذ فروع كثيره واصبح
الهدف هو ان الانسان هو الذي يصنع الحقوق
والانسان هو محور الحقوق ذاته وتحول اكثر
الى اصبح ان شعور الانسان هو الذي يحدد
هويته وانه يجب ان نعترف بذلك بعباره اخرى
اصبح يعني مفهوم الرب خارج المعادله وهناك
مفهوم الانسان الذي يضع القوانين ومن هنا
انفصل المحافظون عن الليبراليون او الوقت
المتطرفون لكن حتى انفسهم مختلفون مع
بعضهم حول هذا الموضوع حول ان الانسان
بوسعي ان يعرف نفسه رجلا او امراه فقط
مجرد انه يشعر انه امراه لانه كما نعرف ان
القوانين ناخذ بريطانيا مثلا يمكن للانسان
ان يشعر انه امراه ويذهب الى طبيب نفسه
ويتحقق منه ويستمع اليه ثم بعد ذلك يوافقه
ويذهب الى العمليه ويغير عمليه الهرمون او
ربما يتخلص من اعضائه التناسليه هذا
القانون يعطيه شهاده يقول انه الان لم يعد
رجلا اصبح امراه لكن مجرد ان يقول الانسان
والله انا اشعر اني امراه وهو رجل
وبالتالي يجب ان تعاملوني كذلك هذا هو
التمدد الليبرالي الخطير الذي يهدد
المجتمع لانه من هذا المنطلق هؤلاء ينادون
ان هذه الحريات حق مطلق وبالتالي يجب ان
تدرس كما تدرس الحريات الاخرى الطفل يجب
ان يعرف انه اذا شعر انه امراه او انه شعر
انه بنت فيجب ان نقبل بذلك ونقول له هذا
شيء جيد لانه هو شعورك ويجب ان نتعامل معه
وبذلك المساله لم تعد معرفيه بمعنى ما هي
الصفات البيولوجيه والحقيقيه للمراه بل
اصبحت هوائيه هي مزاج الشخص ونحن نعرف
ايضا من الاحصائيات ان 60 90% من الاطفال
يغيرون يعني ميولهم هذه عند موصول صل
البلوغ وبالتالي الخطوره تكمن الان بما
يطالب به الواقع انهم يريدون التعليم
الناشئه ان ذلك شيء طبيعي جدا وهذا خطير
جدا لان ذلك القيم التقليديه كلها ستنهار
وسينشا نظام اخلاقي جديد خطير جدا هذا
الموضوع كيف تحول الان الى جزء يعني لجزء
من الصراع السياسي يعني الناس صايره ممكن
تنتخب على اساس موقف الشخص من هذا الموضوع
طبعا يعني في النظام الديمقراطي الناس
تختلف على كثير من الامور والسياسيون
بطبيعتهم يريدون ان يعني طبعا بعضهم
مبدئيون يدخلون السياسه لقناعات تامه
بانهم يدافعون عن اشياء يؤمنون بها وبعضهم
الاخر يميلون الى استخدام هذه الخلافات
وحصد النتائج من خلالها وبذلك تحول الخلاف
من خلاف يعني قانوني يتناقش في المجتمع
لانه حتى الان ليس كل الدول تعترف به تحول
الى يعني حلبه سياسيه كما تفضلت وشرحت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بين محافظين
يتزعمهم الرئيس ترامب وبين الليبراليين
يتزاعمهم الرئيس بايدن وبالتالي كلاهما
يستفيد من هذه الظاهره لكن
ستؤدي في النهايه الى انقسام اكبر في
المجتمع والى يعني خطوره اكبر وتداعياتها
او تبعاتها ستصبح اكثر فاكثر لذلك يجب
النظر اليها من نظره موضوعيه وعلميه
تحل هذه الاشكاليه لانه لانه لا يمكن لشخص
لنفترض انه في بريطانيا في امريكا اصدر
ورقه بانه امراه وذهب الى بلد اخر لا
يعترف بذلك فكيف يمكن التعامل معه هذه
امور خطيره او انه قال انا امراه ودخل الى
الابرهاد النساء وهو رجل بكامل صفاته
الجنسيه يعني هذه مساله معقده جدا
والتعامل معها بناحيه سياسيه فقط دون
الولوج الى تداعياتها القانونيه الاخلاقيه
امر خطير جدا وحده يمكن من الاشياء كمان
المخيفه في هذا الموضوع زي ما ذكرت دكتور
احمد هي انه في سيطره من خلينا نقول
المؤيدين لهذه الفكره على كثير من
المؤسسات الكبيره فيتم الترويج لها لولا
الان انه ايلون ماسك مسك تويتر وسمح لهذا
الراي الاخر انه يظهر ما كنا حنشوف كثير
من هذه الاشياء نحن بنضطر نلجا لبودكاست
واشياء معينه عشان نسمع الراي الاخر يعني
صار في فرض لراي الوك او المدافعين عنه
برايك هذا يعني انه على كم سنه الجايه
حنشوف خلاص انتصار تام لهذه الرؤيه
طبعا يعني هنا يعني المفارقه الشديده ان
الوك يؤمنون ايمان قطعي بحريه التعبير وان
الانسان ان ينتقد وياخذ يعني ما يريد من
اعتراضات لكنهم بداوا في النهايه تحولون
الى استبدااديين يرفضون الراي المعارض
ويجرون الناس الى المحاكم تحت شعار
الحريات هم اساسا جاؤوا من اجل حفظ
الحريات واعطاء الناس حق التعبير
والمعارضه والتظاهر والان هم لا يريدون
ذلك وهنا الخطوره لانه هناك بعض الدعاوى
قدمت ضد بعض الاشخاص في بريطانيا مثلا
عندما قالوا
احدى الموظفات ووضعت يعني في الفيسبوك وفي
تويتر مقالات تقول لها انها لا تؤمن بان
الرجل يمكن ان يصبح امراه وبالتالي احد
الزملاء لها اشتكى من ذلك واعتبرها انها
ذلك يعني فوبيا للجنس ولذلك دخلت الى
المحكمه خلت فيه مشاكل كثيره هذا امر خطير
جدا ويضرب مصداقيه الواق بانهم اساسا هم
اصحاب الحريات وينادون بالحريات وان كل
شيء مفتوح للنقاش لكنهم الان يريدون فرد
رؤيتهم ومن يخالفهم يجرونه الى المحاكم
ويريدون اكثر تعميم هذه الثقافه عن طريق
استخدام الدوله بمعنى خطير جدا اي ان
الدوله تصبح في الديمقراطيه دوله
استبداديه تفرض رايها على الاخرين
المعارضين وعلى سيره الانتخابات الامريكيه
دكتور احمد عجاج نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق مايك بانس قدم الان اوراق ترشحه
رسميا
للرئاسه الامريكيه فهنشوف رايه هو كمان في
موضوع الوقح وحنشوف كيف حتحتدم المعركه
واضح انه في كثير ناس صاروا ميالين كمان
لديسانس لانه جديد في موضوع الوك مثلا
ايلون ماسك كثير زي كده ففي اصبحت فعلا
فاصل يعني هذا الموضوع بين الناس يعني
صحيح فنحن صحيح صحيح جدا يعني
انا حابه بس لانه للاسف دعمنا الوقت فانا
بشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور احمد عجاج شكرا
لك
من ساعات الصباح الاولى واسم الامير هاري
متصدر العناوين والسبب اجدد حلقات الدراما
الجديد للجديده للامير لليوم كان مقرر انه
يتم استجوابه امام المحكمه العليا في
بريطانيا ووقوفه في منصه الشهود فالامير
واحد من بيل مائه شخصيه مشهوره رافعين
دعوه ضد مرر جروب نيوزبيرز او نيوزبيبرز
وهي ومن المؤسسه اللي بتصدر صحيفه ديلي
ميرير صندي بيبل وبيتهموها بانها عمله قرص
على هواتفهم بين سنه سته وتسعين
2010 وحصلت على معلومات تم نشرها على نطاق
واسع وبكدا هذه راح يكون اول فرد رفيع من
العائله المالكه البريطانيه بيوقف امام
محكمه من 130 سنه المؤسسه الاعلاميه
اعترفت انها قرص هاتف الامير
سابقان يعني وقالت انه بقدر يطلب وهو يقدر
تحديدا الامير فعلا عن اللي سووه يطلب
تعويض مادي على هذا الموضوع لكنهم انكروا
التهم الثانيه هاري ما راح يوقف لوحده
امام المحكمه لانه جارير مع العيله
المالكه فالمؤسسه الاعلاميه بتقول انه
مصدر كثير من هذه المعلومات هو العيله
المالكه والعاملين فيها طيب من لندن معنا
من امام المحكمه مراسل العربيه مصطفى
ازارو اهلا فيك معانا مصطفى طبعا الامير
هاري هو واحد من الشخصيات في هذه القضيه
اللي يعني فيها كثير من الاسماء الشهيره
هل نعرف مين اللي حنشوفهم في المحكمه
ان حقيقه هناك ممثلون ربما اقل شهره من
اولئك الذين تم نشر اسمائهم يعني وفي
صدارتهم
ورثت مايكل جورج مايكل المغني الشهير ايضا
فيما يتعلق بصديق المغني
بالاضافه الى ممثلين
وكوميديين لكن الاسماء التي تم اختيارها
هي ثلاثه فقط الى جانب
الامير هاري وبالتالي يعني الكل سيتابع
هذه التغطيه الاعلاميه
لهذه المحاكمه الفريده من نوعها كنا نتوقع
ان يحضر الامير هاري في جلسه الاستماع
اليوم لكن غاب عنها بعد ان قال ممثل ممثله
المحامي شربون بان الامير هاري وصل متاخرا
من لوس انجلوس امس وبسب حضوره حفل عيد
ميلاد ابنته وبالتالي كان هناك توقعات بان
البيانات الافتتاحيه من كلا الجانبين هيئه
الدفاع وهيئه الادعاء ستطلب يوم كامل لكن
بالطبع محامي صحيفه الميرور يعني كانوا
قلقين جدا لانهم خسروا فرصه استجواب
الاميره اليوم ولكن القاضي
قال بان سيمنح الوقت
لفريق يعني
الدفاع
لصحيفه المر وهذا يعني بان سيتم استجواب
الامير هاري ليوم ونصف اليوم يعني غدا
وربما نصف يوم الاربعاء سيكون تحت ضغط
الاسئله
المحققين لصحيفه
نحن الان يعني ربما بنهايه اليوم الاول
لهذه الجلسه كان يفترض ان تنتهي الساعه
الرابعه يعني قبل تقريبا 25 دقيقه لكن
يبدو ان هناك المزيد من من تقديم الادله
والكلمه
محامي سريعا بس بمحامي صحيفه الميرول ايه
صحيفه سريعا كيف رده فعل الناس هل
متعاطفين معهم في هذه القضيه
ان حقيقه
الامير هذه الشخصيه يعني مثيره يعني اغلب
اولئك الذين يدعمونهم من فئات عموريه
شبابيه وبالتالي ربما دعم الامير هاري ليس
بالكبير هناك دعم كبير بالطبع للاسره
المالكه وخاصه الملك تشارلز
وولي عهدي الامير ويليام نحن بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله وطبعا اكيد حنتابع معك
تفاصيل ظهور هاري امام المحكمه شاهد كان
معنا من لندن من امام المحكمه مراسل
العربيه مصطفى زارو شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
في شركه تكنولوجيا في الهند منعت موظفيها
من الخروج دون اذن بطريقه ما يمكن انه
تتخيلوها ولا يمكن حتى ان تخطر على بال
احد خلنا نشوف مع بعض
الفيديو اللي شفتوه لعنصر امن في شركه
هنديه يعني لتكنولوجيا المعلومات وهو كان
بيستخدم سلاسل واسلاك واكفال كبيره علشان
يمنع الموظفين من انهم يخرجوا من الشركه
من دون موافقه المدير وقال انه المدير هو
اللي قال له يعمل كده يعني
طريقه صراحه جديده واكيد ما احد سبقه يعني
على هذه الطريقه ويعني في تنفيذها يعني
طيب المهم انه بعد ما انتشر الفيديو طبعا
على المنصات بشكل كبير بدات ردات الفعل
اللي اتهمت الشركه باستغلال الموظفين
واهانتهم والشركه اضطرت انها تنشر بيان
قالت في انه اجراء مؤسف وانه تم تصحيحه
فورا وانه الموظف اللي عمل هذا التصرف
اعترف بخطا واعتذر
لا احد تجي له افكار من وراء هذه القصه
شاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]